the rumors keep circulating that Marvel
are going to cancel the Kang the
Conqueror storyline thanks to Jonathan
major and his let's say issues welcome
to sidre your SciFi TV and mov
[Music]
Channel a sampling of your greatest hits
if I
may I am Loki Loki Loki I am Loki of
yodenheim of Asgard I was a king king I
am a king and I am burdened with
glorious glorious glorious
purpose
so the rumors won't go away the Jonathan
M's
controversy that's a good word for it
won't go
away I don't
know and with the lowkey finale the
rumors are just swirling ground again
that actually Marvel are going to cancel
the Kang the Conqueror storyline now I
have been speaking to one of the sources
I get to speak to quite a lot and the
story isn't quite as simple as certain
places like giant freakin robot would
like you to believe and no right now at
least the Kang the Conqueror story line
has not been cancelled your savior is
here but it's not quite that simple but
we'll get to that in a minute so first
of all Kang the Conqueror what was
supposed to be the story well he was
supposed to be the next major villain
for the Avengers and there was going to
be an Avengers 5 the K the Conqueror
storyline basically we've already seen
that there's this Multiverse of Madness
and multiple storylines and
timelines now hang on just a minute Loki
storyline has obviously given us an
understanding of that and was it always
supposed to sort of set up the war that
was then supposed to follow the
different variants of the kangs were
basically going to start a
interdimensional conflict that would end
up destroying everything what can I say
I'm a mischievous scam unless the
Avengers could stand up and prevent it
obviously now in Loki season 2 because
the multiple timelines were overwhelming
the TVA the time variance Authority it
ended up actually destroying all of the
timelines the Kang that we saw in Loki
the one who
remains had the sacred timeline the one
timeline and the TVA was supposed to
protect it well that has now been blown
out the Water by Loki who has actually
took the mantle of a god spoilers you're
not a serious man you're right I'm a God
I'm a God I am a God how do you plead
guilty of being the god of Mischief yes
but I'm not going to tell you any more
than that and has given the multiple
timelines the opportunity the
possibility of a fighting chance that
actually there could be a positive
outcome to the upcoming time Wars
or the way that Loki season 2 actually
ended does give them the opportunity to
get out of the Kang story and actually
this could be the last time potentially
we see Kang the Conqueror and it does
give Marvel and Disney an
out now I've got to speak to one of the
sources that I get to speak to and
they're really relatively close to
Disney he says that in the industry
particularly around Disney in Marvel
it's not a very well-kept secret
that Marvel basically have Rewritten the
end of Loki to allow them that if they
need to to cut the Kang the Conqueror
story line there that the way Loki was
written basically will allow them to
either move forwards with it or not
depending on what happens in the future
with Jonathan Mages and what they decide
to do Loki season 2 finale was was
basically Rewritten to give them that
opportunity so how well the time
variants coppers we're basically talking
about how look we're already monitoring
all the different variants of Kang we've
already dealt with a couple of them that
could be the end of it the timelines are
safe the Multiverse of Madness is now
safe with a multiple timelines and Loki
is basically satting his
throne checking it all out and making
sure it's all
sweet so if Marvel decide to go a
different way now they
could but right now that is not the plan
right now they want to move forward to
the Kangal conqueror storyline and the
plan that they've been laying down for
the last few years Kevin F has 100%
decided that they really need to rework
a lot of the plans coming up that
they've been very disappointed by
several of the projects you know that
Marvel's has just pretty much had the
worst opening of any Marvel movie I
believe
so and from what I'm hearing Kevin F is
very aware that he needs to take the
Reigns once again and basically
straighten a few things
out so what can we expect from Marvel in
the next couple of years there will be
changes we've already seen some but I'm
being told that we are going to see more
also we're going going to see far more
simplified story lines I think it's fair
to say that Loki season 2 is actually
one of the best things Marvel have done
in a while and I'm actually really
looking forward to Echo too it looks
like it's going to be good the scrapping
of everything they've done with the
Daredevil reborn and the decision to
basically rewrite it and start again I
think is a good decision because I'm
being told that that story line was
going to tie into
shehulk and the popularity of that has
made them have a think which I think is
going to be a good thing a really good
thing God I hated
She-Hulk so lots of changes ahead and
Marvel are very aware that these changes
could be dramatic and that they've
Rewritten Loki to allow for those
changes to happen if necessary the
Jonathan Major's controversy well they
waiting to see what happens but if they
need to cancel it they've written
themselves way to do it and that is
actually quite clever of them but guys
get to the comments tell me what you
think did you enjoy Loki season 2 do you
think that it makes sense what Marvel
have done here considering the
controversy and what do you see is the
future for Marvel get into the comments
tell me exactly what you think if you
are new to the Channel please like
subscribe hit that Bell notification it
really helps us out and you'll never
miss any of our new videos also you can
go to
s.co which is our dedicated website
where we write articles based on most of
our videos and we try and add a little
bit more detail if you'd suggest also
you can go to
patreon.com Trek where most of our
videos appear first and you get to see
them without the
adverts as always please stay safe and I
see you next
[Music]
time